bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'actuel
sur téléphiles 60 18 26 minutes pour
faire le tour de l'actualité locale
voici les principaux titres de ce 2
octobre à alexandra rosetti première
adjointe au maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux quitte la majorité
elle vient d'annoncer sa démission
explique ne plus être sur la même
longueur d'onde que l'ump alix soviets
elle devrait présenter sa propre liste
ans en mars sous l'étiquette unis pour
sensibiliser à l'importance de valider
son titre de transport la société ski
bus fait appel à la compagnie
d'improvisation théâtrale déclic attrape
les usagers deviennent spectateurs de
saynètes mais pour quel résultat
michel boujenah était à montigny le
bretonneux hier soir pour présenter sa
nouvelle pièce ma ville auto biographie
imaginaire rencontre avec l artiste
juste avant ça va monter sur la scène et
puis invité ce soir les organisateurs de
festival l'an dédié au japon à voisins
le bretonneux l'autre à l'art à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
à l'image du jour là voici les amateurs
de football qui se prépare au choc de ce
soir en champion's league le paris saint
germain affronte au parc des princes le
benfica lisbonne pour la première place
du groupe et la communauté portugaise
très présente dans les yvelines est
prête à soutenir ses joueurs ils seront
à 20000 dans les gradins de la capitale
est encore plus nombreux à la télé comme
dans ce bar elancourt bar restaurant
portugais on a préparé le décor pour
l'ambiance et il faudra de la ferveur
aucune équipe portugaise ne s'est jamais
imposé au parc des princes en coupe
d'europe
autre statistique le psg à domicile est
invaincu en coupe d'europe depuis 2006
soit 15 victoires et 9 nuls en sept ans
on écoute quelques-uns des supporteurs
déjà à présent cet après midi dans ce
bar à elle encourt donc ça s'équivaut ça
s'équivaut bas-fonds championnat il ya
aucun risque je dirais qu'aujourd'hui à
deux équipes en tête pour moi sera
monaco et bg mais jacques d'efficacité
chance de venir faire un bon match et y
et j'irai une victoire au portugal
je pense que ces deux équipes qui se
valent mais c'est des équipes qui sont
un peu d eau revenir à l'heure actuelle
je pense que si ce sera un match qui se
terminera demain pour le paris
saint-germain
je dirais 2 pour paris et -8 chabanais
et à versailles cet après midi le psg a
déjà disputé une rencontre face au
benfica au stade de montgon une
rencontre moins de 19 ans qui s'est
soldé par quatre buts à 1 4 but fort
qu'il portugais pas forcément de bonne
augure pour ce soir
en tout cas ce match se disputait dans
le cadre de la youth celle league
l'équivalent jeunes de la ligue des
champions qui vient de voir le jour
cette saison le psg bon dernier avec
cette défaite 4 buts à 1 dont face aux
portugais de son groupe dernier après
deux journées ce mardi une équipe de
tournage a investi l'auto-école du maine
et à montigny le bretonneux tourne
essentiellement dans le sud des yvelines
vogue la vie sera diffusé courant 2014
nous avons rencontré claire de la
rochefoucauld sa réalisatrice olivier
maniscalco jonathan willeman pour les
images à l'auto-école du manet de
montigny le bretonneux les moteurs des
voitures ont cédé leur place aux moteurs
des caméras une scène d'un téléfilm pour
france 2 il est en effet tournés vers la
vie c'est son nom est tiré d'une
histoire vraie et raconte le parcours
d'une femme atteinte d'un grave cancer
du sein
conseillé par son médecin elle intègre
l'équipage d'un bateau composé de femmes
atteintes du même mal leur but sortir de
la maladie est retrouvé goût à la vie
grâce au sport et l'esprit l'équipe
le film coproduit par la société
telfrance base est opérée en yvelines a
principalement été tournée dans le sud
du département
vous voulez situer le film
dans une 106 passer pour une quotidienne
en tout cas pas pas à paris pas à
bordeaux pas lyon papa dans une grosse
agglomération la gros gros morceau du
film ça a été sur la base nautique de
saint quentin
puisque c'est là on a tourné toutes les
scènes de bateaux les scènes
d'entraînement on a passé huit jours à
la base de saint quentin donc sur 21 ça
a quand même été un gros moment avec des
scènes aussi dans le café de la base
nautique qui est très sympa d'ailleurs
ensuite on a tourné deux jours à
vraiment dans le coeur de saint quentin
dans les galeries marchandes un salon de
coiffure parce que l'amoureuse de didier
qu'il va quitter pour notre coiffeuse la
suite du tournage s'effectuera dans les
prochains jours au studio du père et où
l'appartement des personnages du film a
été reconstitué la fiction sera livré
fin 2013 pour une diffusion courant 2014
élections municipales la première
adjointe de voisins-le-bretonneux va
donc être démissionnés alexandra rosetti
sous l'étiquette udi souhaite se
présenter aux prochaines élections
municipales pour quelle raison elle les
réponses au micro de catherine j'adore
alexandra rosetti marche d'un pas décidé
vers son nouveau destin
mercredi 2 octobre elle adresse sa
lettre de démission au préfet des
yvelines
la première maire-adjointe de
voisins-le-bretonneux élu depuis 12 ans
a annoncé la veille son départ de la
liste majoritaire elle sera dorénavant
conseillère municipale d'opposition
un départ pour mieux rebondir et
constitué sa propre liste
j'ai pas pu tenir mon rôle de maire
adjoint comme je l'aurais voulu
voilà donc je pense que quand il ya un
moment il faut prendre les choses en
main peut-être si on est trop en
désaccord ce qui était le cas depuis un
certain temps maintenant j'ai envoyé
beaucoup de signaux il n'étend pas
entendu bien j'ai pensé qu'il était
temps de peut-être proposer un autre
regard sur la vie de notre ville un
autre regard sur la gestion financière
un autre regard sur la gestion
associative la masse salariale
représente pas loin de 70 % du budget de
fonctionnement de la ville donc c'est
quand même une part énorme et je suis
absolument convaincu que le management
va être au coeur des économies qu'on va
pouvoir faire une adjointe qui passe
dans l'opposition un cas de figure qui
n'est pas sans rappeler le scénario des
dernières élections de mars 2008 à
voisins-le-bretonneux à l'époque un
maire adjointe joëlle le nom avait lui
même décidé de monter sa propre liste
l'histoire semble se répéter
c'est très compliqué d'être élu et de
d'avoir le sentiment que parfois la
direction administrative prend le pas
sur ce que nous sur ce que nous
pourrions proposer et c'est nous qui
devons répondre de nos soit devant les
électeurs et
ça c'est quelque chose que peut-être
d'autres élus n'ont pas accepté non plus
par le passé alexandra rosetti qui
discutent justement d'un rapprochement
avec joël le nom responsable
départemental du parti radical va
solliciter l'investiture de son parti
lui dei
elle aura face à elle deux candidats
déjà déclarés jeu le maire sortant ump
alexis piette et le socialiste jean h
prochain conseil municipal le 10
décembre un conseil particulier pour
celle qui va dorénavant siéger dans
l'opposition
une autre candidature officialisée celle
de philippe benassaya bois d'arcy pour
l'ump déjà conseiller municipal
d'opposition il siège face à claude
juillet socialiste lui aussi candidat en
mars pour un quatrième mandat à montigny
le bretonneux pierre déjean vient lui
d'être nommé chef de file du parti de
gauche avec pour mission de s'adresser
aux militants critiques d'europe
écologie les verts et du parti
socialiste doit s'adresser aussi aux
composantes du front de gauche la gauche
qui s'étaient rassemblés en 2008 aux
dernières municipales derrière les
socialistes face aux centristes soutenu
e par l'ump
ok la gendarmerie des yvelines c'est
désormais possible elle vient d'ouvrir
sa propre page facebook le groupement
installé à versailles entend donner des
conseils de prévention et d'information
son slogan contribuant ensemble à
promouvoir la sécurité et l'esprit
citoyen elle compte à ce jour un peu
moins des 2 400 fans à noter tout de
même que la gendarmerie informe aussi
des contrôles routiers en cours cela
peut toujours servir avant de prendre la
route
la 4g qui s'installe en france et dans
le département après orange sur vélizy
plus particulièrement c'est au tour de
bouygues sur saint quentin en yvelines
notamment et sur presque l'intégralité
des yvelines d'ailleurs pour l'instant
sfr ne couvre pas notre secteur oui qui
se veut le leader dans cette nouvelle
technologie en s'adressant depuis hier à
63% de la population française contre et
40 % à la fin de l'année pour ses
principaux concurrents
l'improvisation qui s'invite dans les
transports en commun ski bus avec la
compagnie déclic théâtre compagnie de
trappes pour sa campagne de
communication vont donc travailler
ensemble pour communiquer autour de la
validation des titres de transport
aujourd'hui lé passager de ligne de
trappes étaient concernés ils ont
assisté à des saynètes de musiciens et
de comédiens masqués anthony rech
la vie nomade
ces comédiens de la compagnie déclic
théâtre doivent surprendre plus d'un
voyageur en chansons il s'invite aux
arrêts de bus ou à bord des véhicules et
explique aux usagers l'importance de la
validation du passe navigo
le bien est gratuit à chaque fois vous
le mettez à chaque fois il n y avait pas
conserver mamadou messager du couple
surtout pas bits et voyageurs qui
possèdent leur titre de transport mais
qui ne le valide pas s'expose à une
amende de 32 euros
la validation du navigo a également un
impact direct sur le fonctionnement des
lignes de bus
il faut qu'ils jouent leur rôle il faut
qu'il soit bien qu'on sache qui sont
dans les bus et pour ça c'est que la
validation qui peut nous le dire parce
que s'ils voyagent sans valider même
s'ils ont leur titre de transport
c'est un problème si disons leur titre
ils sont en rêvent ils ont leur équipe
de transport mais cette validation est
très importante parce que ça veut dire
qu'ils sont en bus et on peut dire
attention sur cette ligne là ya vraiment
trop de monde
il faut mettre un bus articulé où il
faut demander des renforts au cif dire
qu'il faut pas plus de bus ou une
fréquence plus importante
une première campagne de comptage sur le
réseau ce qui lui sera effectué entre le
7 et le 17 octobre prochain pour adapter
le trafic
la compagnie de transport saint
quentinois effectué 17 millions de
voyages par an chantier d'arrêt de seine
événement annuel sur voisins le
bretonneux nous avons choisi de
s'attarder sur un compte jeune public un
spectacle ludique et interactif il était
une fois les savants menée par la
compagnie à la farandole des comptes
yolaine torres
très quitte à s'en plaindre
sophie et conteuse depuis sept ans mais
quelques minutes avant d'entrer en scène
le stress est toujours bien présent dans
le cadre du festival vit six mois
chantier d'arrêt de seine
il était une fois les savants raconte
que la science est partout et qu'elle a
abouti à de grandes découvertes alors
contre moi comment la perte du premier
enfant et là je me suis aperçu que ce
que je préférais faire j'aurais fait ça
toute la journée c'est lui raconter des
histoires ce qui me plaît le plus c'est
transmettre un message
et échanger être ensemble ce cette magie
cette alchimie qui se fait lors de la
raconter
elle est exceptionnelle et elle n'est
pas prévisible elle n'est jamais pareil
pour capter l'attention des enfants
sophie a ses petits secrets par la voix
par les changements de voies faire le
personnage les parfois les joues et même
parce que la conteuse en fait elle ne
vit pas une histoire elle a fait vivre à
la fait revivre serre qu'elle va
raconter une histoire et en la racontant
elle explique comment ça s'est passé
parce qu'elle elle était témoin elle
était là ou pas
en dix ans
je pense que c'est une manière au fonds
de se raconter de vous raconter son
intime et puis j'aime le partage et se
partage c'est ça non
on passe aux invités de cette édition
ils sont venus nous présenter la semaine
du japon céline sylvia vicens bonsoir
coordinatrice au centre alfred de vigny
à voisins et christophe barbier
animateur socioculturel dans ce centre
pourra vous également
elle nous parlera du festival culturel
de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines clown ergis
bonsoir vous êtes en charge de la vie
étudiante à l'université est de saint
quentin en yvelines on commence par
cette semaine du japon une culture qui
séduit qui intrigue beaucoup
d'occidentaux c'est très très riches est
ce que vous allez dresser un panorama
complet au cours de cette semaine on a
été des choix ouais ça n'a pas été
possible c'est trop riche
c'est beaucoup trop riches donc on a
fait on essayait de fins de faire un
petit peu l'histoire du japon enfin les
grosses périodes et en termes de
conférence on va dire voilà on a parlé
du sac et on parle du larzac et au logis
oui la saq et aux excès précis la
calligraphie est également oui ça une
activité pardon qui a très bien marché
donc sur la semaine notamment de
conférences aussi sur la métallurgie et
la fabrication du sabre ce soir à 20
heures
donc si on a encore que ça intéresse
aujourd'hui mercredi vous parlez des
conférences il ya des animations aussi
s'est il n'y a pas que des conférences
les gens peuvent participer s'impliquer
aussi voilà il ya un dîner spectacle en
clôture on met l'accent là dessus parce
qu'il ya une riche programmation
sportive culturelle qui a élaboré
christophe donc il va y avoir des
démonstrations local loop de l'école de
kendo deux voisins les associations sont
impliqués voilà qu il me semble toujours
d'impliquer les habitants
il va y avoir de la danse du ty coq et
une percussion bien spécifique japonaise
vous êtes incollable en culture
japonaise du coup oui
sur ça vous parlez des différentes
conférences y en a une aussi qui
concerne les deux guerres qui ont subi
le week c'était hier s'explique par le
japon comment ça s'est déroulé quel
genre de public s'intéresse aussi à
cette partie historique dont on parle
moins souvent quand on parle du japon
bon bah là on niveau en termes de
tranches d'âge voulait dire vie entre
otages voilà c'était plus des adultes et
voyez des adultes donc il ya eu peu de
jeunes
il a même pas eu de jeunes sur ces
conférences est là sur la semaine votre
objectif c'est de toucher tous les
toutous les wagons comme tout le monde à
sa famille que j'ai d'ailleurs sur la
calligraphie à quelques white quelques
jeunes le dîner spectacle il y aura des
familles sur la conférence rsa
régalement donc taillé à des jeunes des
moins jeunes ne s'intéressent un peu
tout le monde en a même des personnes
qui sont leurs vous qu'est ce qui vous
séduit dans la culture japonaise à moi
au départ ça a été les arts martiaux
voilà ça a été les arts martiaux mais
après ça a été ça a été aussi ce qui me
fascine surtout dans japon ac c'est leur
artisanat donc vraiment su garder une
tradition vivante et en artisanat
vraiment spécifique qui s'inspirent de
leurs traditions séculaires et des
traditions aux modernes qu'ils ont au
japon et ça en fait un artisanat
particulier de très bonne qualité
moi il ya ça qui m'attire leur
abnégation dans le travail dans les
oeuvres qui réalise c'est votre groupe
au japon qui a poussé a programmé une
semaine
oui autour de ce mois par plaisir pour
la rentrée est ce que pour faire
découvrir certaines devaient aussi parce
que c'est moins connu par exemple à sa
théologie la plupart des personnes quand
il s'était distingué considère dans les
restaurants chinois vous savez ça rien
avoir du tout c'est ça se rapproche du
vin de table
chez nous c'est des boissons comprises
entre 14 et 17 % il ya une variété
beaucoup de variétés de saké vraiment
savait rien à voir eh bien on va parler
du dîner spectacle ça c'est le rendez
vous de clôture le grand moment festif
de cette semaine se déroulera le 5
octobre avoir gagné 5 octobre pour
s'inscrire les allergiques à demain soir
à la clôture demain soir et tous les
ateliers aussi sont également encore
prête en partie ce qui est le sien or
certains encore en allant la conférence
ikebana eu un énorme succès donc c'est
intéressant
est posée par contre là tant pis tant
pis là il fallait s'inscrire plus vite
c'est en fait le vini côté université de
versailles saint quentin ce n'est pas le
japon ce sont les cultures urbaines qui
sont à l'honneur jusqu'au 18 octobre à
partir de demain
pourquoi le choix des cultures urbaines
se demander pourquoi le choix du japon
pourquoi ce soit des cultures ben c'est
un thème qui est fédérateur qui est
proche des étudiants je pense que ça
parle à peu près tout le monde sur le
hip-hop et le street art
oui alors l'action émission le hip hop
parce que sur le territoire de saint
quentin en fête les 30 ans de vie peuple
cette année la présence les 30 ans de la
présence du hip hop à saint quentin en
yvelines et du coup on sait on a été
associée la programmation pulsations
urbaine
c'est sur la tôle mort à proximité des
agglomérations voit la saison 2013 2014
effectivement les hip hop qu'un petit
peu n'est en tout cas la danse hip hop
sur saint quentin en yvelines avec la
compagnie black blanc beur qui a fait 50
ans elle encore plus précisément il ya
déjà quelques années donc avec le
festival vouliez donner une autre
tonalité un petit peu à 700 rentrée
étudiante
oui voilà
on voulait je pense accueillir la
communauté universitaire après la
rentrée donner un mouvement un peu
sévère pour rassembler et s'est pas
ouverte aux étudiants non plus voilà
donc là aussi s'ouvrir sur le territoire
en proposant des activités ouvertes à
tous donc pas mal de démonstration on
aura une démonstration de parcours une
performance graffiti et on a trois
expositions dont une qui est qui a déjà
débuté qui a déjà les secrets d'une
révolution culturelle exactement elle
était organisée par la communauté
d'agglo 'je veux plus te ment dans le
cadre de pulsations urbaine et elle est
hébergée dans le hall du bâtiment veut
bancs de l'université à granby en cour
demain c'est la soirée d'ouverture
soirée d'inauguration avec une brooklyn
bloc party exactement une block party
c'est quoi alors ben justement voulait
célébrer le les prémices du peuple début
du peuple et du cou
on a on a trouvé ce nom de pour le thème
de la soirée d'inauguration
en épluchant un peu les historiques
cette inauguration
alors ça va se dérouler dans un premier
temps va faire le vernissage de
l'exposition une pop-up l'agenda secret
d'une révolution culturelle
puis on aura on aura un buffet qui
organisé par le conflit ticket wiki
organisés et prêts proposés par le crous
de de l'université et on aura une petite
animation hip hop avec les danseurs
amateurs de deux illicites dance 2
voisin deux roses
voilà c'est dément voici la médiation
sur le territoire 56 ans est rentré mais
là ce sera ce sont les danseurs amateurs
donc plutôt des plutôt des jeunes c'est
une culture qui vous parle dans cette
culture et foi oui oui bien sûr j'en ai
appris beaucoup d'ailleurs parce que en
organisant le festival on a appris
beaucoup et elle est beaucoup plus large
que ce qu'on peut penser et c'est aussi
un peu ce qu'on a essayé de montrer et
c'est ouvert au grand public on le
rappelle bien sûr site internet de aussi
bien du centre alfred de vigny pour la
semaine du japon et que le site internet
spécial qui a été mis en place à
l'université autour est de ces festival
des cultures urbaines pour la rentrée se
sont affichées les deux sites sont à
l'antenne vous pouvez vous y rendre pour
connaître toute la programmation merci à
tous les trois nous parler de cette
rentrée festive à voisins et à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines culture
toujours pour refermer ce journal michel
boujenah sur la scène de la salle
jacques brel à montigny le bretonneux
pour son spectacle ma vie auto
biographie imaginaire ses terres et hier
soir il a joué devant une salle comble
c'est la deuxième fois seulement qu'il
proposait son one man show rencontre
interview menée par aurélia de bissy
juste avant que l'artiste ne monte sur
scène michel boujenah vent soir bonsoir
on vous retrouve donc ce soir à la salle
jacques brel à montigny vous présentez
votre one man show ma vie une
autobiographie imaginaire c'est vrai
qu'à l'heure où le public est plutôt
friand des téléréalités des d'une vie un
peu cachée des stars on a envie de
connaître leur vie réelle en fait vous
vous présentez une vie imaginaire
pourquoi parce que parce que ma vie à
moi au premier degré elle a aucun
intérêt et que c'est que ce spectacle
c'est c'est plus une réflexion sur la
vie que ma vie à moi alors évidemment
dedans il ya des des histoires qui me
touche de près c'est en train de
quelques réalités mais je t'ai je dirais
pas quoi mais c'est très imaginaire
c'est c'est plus beau de rêver sa vie
que de la vie quels thèmes que vous
abordez tout au long de ce spectacle bat
l'enfance l'exil bizarrement la mort
la nostalgie la tunisie où est un peu la
tunisie oui au début surtout lalami
relation amoureuse à l'adolescence avec
les filles
évidemment tout ça est très drôle enfin
en principe des drôles ou touchants mais
moi je peux pas là assis dans un
fauteuil sénat je sais je suis incapable
de deux de vous faire rire comme ça de
quoi on va rien de ma capacité à tourner
en dérision tout par exemple quand un
gamin de 10 ans à 4 heures du matin
réveil ses parents leur disant à quoi ça
sert de vivre s'il ya la face pour
mourir pourquoi la vie était fait mais
pourquoi la vie est éphémère et l'amour
éternel et le père lui dit mais à 4
heures du matin tu veux savoir faire tu
veux pas attendre lutter tu vois et
quand il dit mais pourquoi on dit mourir
de plaisir
pourquoi la mort c'est un plaisir
pourquoi andy mourir de joie ce que la
mort si si joyeux que ça et et l'opéra
monde 2010 par exemple fils mais je n'en
peux plus
je meurs de sommeil et il lui dit tu
vois qui a dit pourquoi on meurt de
sommeil c'est il ya à la fois des choses
qu sur un enfant qui se pose est que ces
questions toutes simples sur la vie il
ya des choses beaucoup plus délirantes
il ya une femme qui fait qu' à partir
des cauchemars ce que le dernier
cauchemar qu'elle a fait s'est réveillée
elle était dans la peau de françois
hollande c'est compliqué surtout en ce
moment pour dans la vie j'ai très
pudique y compris alors que je le suis
un peu moins d'un spectacle mais on va
on va on va rire où on va être touchée
de d'une mère qui dit enfin la vérité
puisque elle dit que en gros que les
maires finalement
or le rôle qu'on leur a donné le rôle
qu'elles ont assumé c'est d'être
inquiète et de nourrir leurs enfants
s'est dit en fait moi j'avais pas envie
de ça du tout en fait j'étais pas
inquiète mais si j'avais pas été
inquiète
on aurait dit que jeudi j'étais une
mauvaise mère monfils murray dit maman
je veux faire un test de maternité au
bout de 35 ans de travail seul sur scène
je suis toujours incapable par mon
travail je suis toujours voyez je suis
pas un homme d'interviews chpa nombre de
télévisions je suis pas loin de tout ça
je suis juste un garçon qui aime
raconter des histoires sur scène et
quels ont été les premiers retours alors
de cette première date c'était bien mais
c'était un titre on était content cette
espèce était super content on va bien
voir comment ce petit bébé va va
continuer à arriver toute attente cette
tournée bien sûr bien sûr tout le temps
tout le temps mais tout le temps on m'a
même quand je vais faire paris lille
il évolue tous les jours tous les jours
tous les jours il arrive un petit truc
ou un gros truc on change est vrai avec
moi ici une écriture qui est vivante je
suis pas un autre juge pas mort comme
auteur ou encore wii donc je peux encore
écrire y compris quand je joue bien sûr
merci je vous en prie michel boujenah de
cet entretien je vous retrouve demain
18h en direct à 19h à 22h30 également
pour le 7-8 l'aktu d'ici là nos
reportages et nos précédentes éditions
sont à retrouver sur le site internet tv
fil 78 points comme également accessible
via vos smartphones très bonne soirée à
demain